What's wrong with these people? Actually, I think you should
debate me on Destiny's stream again. Yo, you're the one who's
on a cruise crashing out. Don't play with me. Either accept the
debate or shut the [__] up. And we need to do that
immediately because you're lying about LLCs. LLCs are totally
dark >> Bro, what is wrong with these I'm going TO CRASH
OUT.
>> THAT'S FINE. THAT LIKE IF that's your perspective, that's
okay. My standard for journalism is a bit higher. No, no, this
is your this is slap journalism you're describing. No, it's not.
Destiny, I freelance for the mainstream media. I can't I just
wrote a big piece for Vanity Fair and the Guardian last week.
I can't write for those organizations if I was accepting dark
>> Well, first of all, yes, you can. Of course, you can.
You don't have to declare every single income source or any Of
course, you can. Yeah, of course, you can. And so, I don't think
that Destiny is necessarily actually stating that this is a dark
money group. I think he's pretending to be an idiot in order
to use the same kind of insults that Taylor Lorenz and Hasan
[__] have used against other creators against Taylor
Lorenz. So, I I I think all that's If I had to guess, he's pretending
to be an idiot. He doesn't actually think it's dark money, but
may maybe he'll come out and be like, "No, no, no, it is dark
money." Like I I don't know. We'll see. >> Very [__]
annoying to to listen to her make a bunch of points that are
untrue again in their conversation and Destiny miss on all of
the things that are actually untrue and keep pushing on the things
that are that he's wrong on. Like Like he claims on the [__]
Omidyar [__] Like he is he is just wrong. Like Omidyar
does not qualify as dark money. Not under her definition, not
under anybody's definition. It just does not qualify as dark
money at all. >> I think Destiny's getting confused or
maybe maybe I'm wrong, but the guy Omidyar, the guy with the
last name Omidyar, he has donated like $40 million to the What
is it called? The 1630 Fund. But I don't think that the group
that she is a part of, like this incubator program for journalists,
it's like a journalist cohort. I think that is directly funded
by that Omidyar guy, but it's not technically dark money. >> Uh
Omidyar is uh one of the most transparent organizations to ever
exist, and so it's just not
it's just not a good argument to keep pushing on the Omidyar
stipend that she gets. And I had this conversation with a number
of content creators who stopped pushing the Omidyar thing because
they also did not realize how wrong this thing was, but they
just kind of copied Destiny and repeated the that he was saying.
>> Wow. Wow. Do you want to go over those tweets with Z
and Z and Taylor Lorenz today? >> Look, we got them all.
>> Uh @TaylorLorenz is too slow to understand that an LLC
is dark money by another name, but that's understandable considering
she calls herself a renowned journalist when she's fired from
every uh major publication for being
I okay, I don't know if she's been
That would be weird if if she just if Z just claimed this without
knowing. Okay. >> It's like LLC's dark money by another
name. It's like, okay.
No, that's just a company.
This is just a for-profit business.
You wouldn't funnel dark money through a for-profit business.
Do you guys know why you wouldn't do that? Because you'd have
to pay taxes on it.
You don't take contributions to a for through a for-profit business.
Cuz there's a structure where you can take contributions through
a nonprofit. It's a 501c4 hybrid structure, okay? You take the
contributions. You can hide the identities of the people contributing.
There's simply no reason to do it ever. LLC equals dark money,
but dark money means money you don't know the origin of, and
we do in her case. In Well, in Taylor's case, yeah. Yeah, exactly.
But like, it's also dark money for political purposes. Um like,
dark money is is unknown funding for political purposes, right?
And these people have absolutely no humility. I don't know. I
don't know.
I'm pretty sure they're just stupid as [__] on this
though.
Like, they're intentionally misunderstanding all of the commentary
on it. And it's like
why are we pretending that it's dark
like these things are of a kind. They're
One is set up one thing is set up one structure is set up to
take infinite
like like unknown source money and the other one is set up as
a private business owned by a person. It's like the person is
the person who can put money into it.
It's just Pierre Omidyar or tick I guess technically anybody
who's on the LLC. Anybody who's a part of the ownership structure
of the LLC. But I think that's when they incorporate. I think
I think some of the stuff like if you wanted to add a new person
to the LLC, I think that ends up being public.
But I'm not totally sure.
But in any case, there's just no reason to expect that for Omidyar
Network there's anybody other than Pierre Omidyar or Pamela Omidyar
there.
There's just no reason. Okay, anyway. An LLC is not a dark money
group. LOL or sorry, is not a dark money group. LOL I operate
my own LLC for my business and that is not dark money. Also,
I've never been fired from a single journalism job. I really
fear some of you have fallen into psychosis.
Dude, I do like I do like Taylor
just being like passive-aggressive all of the time. Just being
like I'm I'm really sorry for you guys.
I'm really sorry that this happened to you guys.
I'm really so I'm I'm sorry that this happened to you guys. For
people like Z who are confused, dark money refers to spending
meant to influence political outcomes where the donor of the
money is not disclosed. I've never accepted I've never accepted
money for one, any political effort, nor have I accepted money
two, where the funder is not
No, you don't understand. It's from a LLC possibly. I don't even
know if it's By the way, I don't know if it's from the LLC.
I assume it's from the LLC cuz I don't see it in the 501c3 financial
as like a payment they're making.
I don't see that. I hate that we relatively lionize because those
aren't nearly as bad as the other reasons. Well, no, I I'm just
laughing at Taylor like being passive-aggressive all the time.
I'm not even I'm not trying to lionize Taylor particularly. Although
I think in this case she didn't do anything wrong. I've actually
pointed out the things that I do think Taylor's done wrong. Like
I do think Taylor leaned into the Israel thing outside of the
article. Like the idea that people in chorus were being paid
not to talk about Israel or something. I do think she leaned
into that outside of the article and I criticized that.
So I'm not trying to be like unfair, but I think the criticisms
of Taylor are not good criticisms. There are good criticisms
you can make of Taylor's
There are good criticisms you can make of chorus, but people
don't want to make those criticisms. People want to have like
a different proxy war about
that is totally irrelevant.
Very goofy. All right. Taylor Lorenz, whenever you're done sending
30 more tweets about me back-to-back, I formally challenge you
to a debate about this on at Omniliberal stream. What is wrong
with this person? Okay.
Debate what? There's nothing to debate. I've never accepted dark
money. I can't as a journalist who writes for major outlets with
strict journalistic ethics
she says this
I will say the circular argument is going to really really trigger
people. It's really going to upset people. I formally challenge
you to a duel on Yummy Yummy
Uh seriously. Seriously though.
Seriously though.
Oh my god. Okay.
But she does do the circular thing. Where she's like, "No, that
can't be dark money cuz I'm a journalist so I can't accept dark
money."
Why? Why is it dark money? Well, why isn't it dark money? Well,
I'm a journalist I can never accept dark money. Like dude, come
on. Make me This is fine. This is a good argument. This is better.
Okay. Now,
there is some argument that well, you could fund journalists.
It's very similar to the
Uh but it's not the same either. Like there's technically a kind
of argument here where you could say, well, Pure Media R funds
journalists who like take a specific lean, and that's sort of
political spending that he's propping up journalists who have
like similar politics to him.
But then even then, all of it is transparent. You know who's
getting the funding and where they're getting it from. So, like
it's not the same again, right? It's totally different again.
Anyway, we can debate how LLCs can be a form of dark money and
often are. We can debate about Chorus. We can debate about your
age. What laws I think can be changed and to Can we debate about
whether or not you've had plastic surgery to get the chin to
that
I'm pretty sure when when Clavicular finally goes into a surgeon
to the for the double jaw surgery, he's going to have a picture
of Z. He's going to be like, "Yeah, like this. Like do this.
Make me like this. Okay. Okay. What laws I think can be changed,
and I'm going to set the record straight after speaking to a
lot of the Chorus creators and founders. There's nothing to debate.
There are basic facts which are not debatable, which are not
debatable things. It's a fact that I've never once accepted dark
money. Now you're throwing out other weird things like I don't
put my birth date  address online. Why would I debate
that?
Girl, you're the one who's crashing out. Don't play with me.
Either accept a debate or shut the [__] up.
Oh, sorry we didn't get this one. Debate what? There's nothing
to debate. I've never accepted Oh.
I've never accepted dark money. I can't as a journalist who writes
for major outlets with strict journalistic ethics standards.
I'm sorry this fact has sent you into a year-long crash out.
Girl, you're the one who's on a cruise crashing out. Don't play
with me. Either accept a debate or shut the [__]
up.
Debate what? You can't debate a fact. I've never accepted dark
money. I can't as a journalist who writes dude. Okay.
They're they're looping a lot. Very cool.
And apparently Z just posted a video. I'm guessing the video
is going to be like, "Actually, I think you should debate me
on Destiny's stream again."
Oh, this is all the same thing. Okay. We'll see. We'll see. Maybe
maybe it's not just that. Actually, Taylor Lorenz, you need to
debate me on Destiny's stream and
and we need to do that immediately because you're lying about
LLCs. LLCs are totally dark money.
LLCs are totally dark money.
By my mother's mandible.
>> The dark money queen herself, Taylor Lorenz, is back
and this time she's back with a vengeance because last night
my friend Destiny absolutely cooked her on his stream. And because
of that, she's taking out her anger on Twitter on everybody else.
If you haven't heard about Taylor Lorenz, it's probably because
she's irrelevant and nobody knows about her. Except she's a self-proclaimed
renowned journalist that's been let go from every single major
publication
because of how unserious she is. But she was relevant for a very
small blip of time about 6 months ago when she released a ridiculous
article in The Wire where she talked about the 1630 Fund that's
funding a group called Chorus. Chorus is a group of political
influencers on the left that is trying to fight the alt-right
pipeline online. Now, the biggest issue with this article is
that she claimed that these content creators had to say specific
talking points in order to get paid that were passed down from
the Democratic Party. Something has denied as as well as all
of the influencers that they've interviewed in >> Um that's
actually not true. That is a subtle lie right there.
I don't believe it's implied in the article. Yeah, she says The
Wire. I don't think it's implied in the article that
they are restricted. They have to say things one-to-one. It says
they are paid to push Democrat messaging. But that is objectively
what they're meant to be doing. That is objectively the original
like first principle of
Not that they have to, that they're like allowed to.
They're empowered to, okay? What the [__] is that
accent? I don't know what that accent is. I don't know. It's
like partially Australian?
I don't know. She gets all She gets a couple of the things from
Like she says no unironically. Oh, she grew up in Australia.
Well, there you go. There you go.
>> time about 6 months ago when she released a ridiculous
article in The Wire where she talked about the 1630 Fund that's
funding a group called Chorus. Chorus is a group of political
influencers on the left that is trying to fight the alt-right
pipeline online. Now, the biggest issue with this article is
that she claimed that these content creators had to say specific
talking points in order to get paid that were passed down from
the Democratic Party.
>> Yeah, the article doesn't claim that. It >> Something
that Chorus has denied as as well as all of the influencers that
they've interviewed in that group, and she still to this day
has not provided any evidence for it. I simply asked
>> Like they just lie. They just lie. Okay. >> It's
true during this time to provide that evidence along with a lot
of other people, and she completely crashed out at me online.
The funniest part about all of this is that the woman who's claiming
that everybody should have journalistic integrity clearly has
none of her own because she's also taking money from a dark money
funded LLC by a billionaire. What's also incredibly
>> Dark money funded LLC by a billionaire.
So, it's not dark money.
IT'S DARK MONEY FUNDED BY A BILLIONAIRE. OH, so you know who
the billionaire is? Is it an anonymous billionaire or is the
fund literally named after the
>> Dude, what the [__] is wrong with this person?
What is WRONG WITH THESE PEOPLE?
BRO, what is wrong with these I'm going to crash out. I'm going
to go online and have a crash out, okay? I'm [__]
What is happening? Dude, it's like apparently a bunch of billionaires
got together and went, "You know, we could do this in a tax-deductible
way, so that the the the actual business, the the charitable
entity, the nonprofit, doesn't have to pay taxes on income, right?"
Or we could create a structure where we get taxed on our contributions,
and we just
we just give a ton of money to the
What do you guys want to do? Structure where we just like give
money to this LLC, and it counts as income for that LLC?
Do we want to do that, or do we want to do the 501c4
hybrid structure, where we can still donate anonymously,
and it doesn't get taxed? Yes, even less. This hypothetically,
this could happen in a completely world, yes.
But you would be Do you want The problem is is that there's a
structure where those billionaires' identities could be protected,
right?
And they could donate way, way, way more
for those same causes.
This LLC structure that they're proposing is totally
And it's clearly not what the Omidyar Network is set up for.
The Omidyar Network is set up so Sam Sorry, sorry. Pierre Omidyar
can like fund things he cares about.
Also possibly like so that he can
It's it's essentially set up so he can not pay taxes on doing
his own charitable work, right? Like And when I say not pay taxes,
you pay taxes for income tax. It's just so you don't get double
taxed, right? So you don't give it to the charity, and then the
charity has to pay taxes for their own income tax. Yeah, well,
there the logic is is hypothetically, because the funding structure
of the LLC is not transparent, that it could hypothetically take
money from other people.
But then, the thing that they're calling dark money is a 501c4,
a thing that is explicitly designed from its bones, this this
501c4 hybrid structure, 501c4 LLC, is explicitly designed from
its bones to take anonymous donations in large
Like it's explicitly meant to keep money dark and take large
amounts of money in, right? For certain issues. And
so that it's like you're you're describing something that hypothetically
you could not know, but that is like in in the case of the Omidyar
Network is very transparent about what they're doing. So you're
taking this like this hypothetical thing and trying to make it
a comparison.
And it's like dude, they're not they're not of a kind at
They're not similar at all. You're like taking the like there's
a 99.99999%
chance that the Omidyar Network is just Pierre Omidyar and his
wife.
Right? And you're saying that .000001%
chance is the same as something that is designed to do the exact
thing that there's a tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny chance of with
the Omidyar Network.
That we're trying to compare these
But it's stupid. There's no reason.
>> The funny to me is that somebody that claims to care
so deeply about dark money, to my knowledge, has never investigated
any Republican dark money at all. She's not investigated Turning
Point USA and Charlie Kirk. She's not investigated Nick Shirley.
She's not investigated Ben Shapiro or the Daily Wire. The list
goes on. So here's the thing, Taylor. >> Well, I would
imagine is that not because she'd have contacts close to
Why does she have to Why does she have to go after those things?
Wouldn't she have contacts close to this? Wouldn't she have been
friends with some of the influencers who are part of this cuz
she covers like she's in these circles.
That doesn't that explain how she probably got this story? She
said she has looked into them. Sure.
Like I I've heard this article as well. Um why didn't Taylor
do an article on Tenet? Why isn't she focus on Tenet Media? It's
like what? Wait, why is it always Hold on. Can Can explain to
me why people will defend Hutch but not Taylor Lorenz? How does
that make sense? I thought it was okay for Hutch to do what he
does because it's okay to have like one guy who watches the watcher
and it's okay to have one guy who looks internally and critiques
the group.
Right? Isn't that the defense people usually have of Hutch?
why wouldn't that defense apply to Taylor Lorenz even if she
did look internally? But she also like straight up Okay, she's
the doxing queen. She like straight up doxes the Lives of TikTok
account. It's not like she doesn't cover Republicans. All of
these things are like so transparent
in what they're doing. It's just team sports. And I'm I'm just
calling out the bad arguments. If they just made my arguments
for the critiques, they could get as angry about some of the
critiques they're making. Like, why has nobody I I I'm apparently
the only one who who watched the Taylor Lorenz Glenn Greenwald
interview right after that article released where I think she
pretty explicitly says, "I think these people are shilling for
It's not in the article, but it is very clear to me that Taylor
Lorenz had like some thoughts about that article and about what
Corus is doing
that she didn't include in the article, right? That's criticizable,
but nobody even talked about that. Nobody's even made that criticism.
I've not heard Destiny make that criticism. I've not heard Lonerbox
make that criticism. I've not heard Z make that criticism. Instead,
I hear I haven't heard Dude,
I watched I watched the I listened to Lonerbox's stream this
morning while I was in the car and at the hospital. I was just
listening to my headphones. I can't listen to that on stream,
okay?
Oh. I It was very frustrating. It was very frustrating and
I could hear the World of Warcraft sounds in the background,
so I'm like, "Oh, he's like probably barely even paying attention."
Lonerbox always made the dumb argument that a media network is
dark money. It's Well, it's like Well, yeah, that's where Destiny
took it from, I believe.
And while it is like you could say that hypothetically this LLC
obfuscates
some donations.
There's just no reason to believe that it does.
And maybe you want to say that Taylor Lorenz needs to know 100%
that that couldn't possibly be the case, but then you technically
don't know that for your own job.
Like if she worked at the Washington Post, how is this substantially
different than working at the Washington Post where Jeff Bezos
pays the bills?
Where that if if that company is underwater, somebody is paying
for like the the salaries to still go out, right? Like I tried
to ask this to people. It's like, "Okay, so you're a journalist
working at the Washington Post. You don't know where your money
comes from directly. Like you actually you actually don't know
the funding structure of that company." Technically, that's an
LLC almost certainly.
Is that dark money?
Cuz it's dark money in the same way as the Omidyar Network.
So, what the [__] are we doing here? Right? It's
it's obviously not that you need 100% certainty, 100% transparency
on exactly how your money comes in. Right? It's that what is
the what is the structure of how you get your money or how you
get some funding? What is that set up to do? What is the goal
of of that thing? Well, it's pretty obvious with the Omidyar
Network that it's not to hide who's paying you.
It's not.
Oh, okay.
Uh this is good cuz it's actually rage inducing so I can just
keep I didn't even finish this Z video. It's actually rage inducing
so it's waking me up. >> dark money at all. She's not investigated
Turning Point USA and Charlie Kirk. She's not investigated Nick
Shirley. She's not investigated Ben Shapiro or the Daily Wire.
The list goes on. So, here's the thing, Taylor. Instead of just
defending yourself in my comment section because you're too scared
to debate, just formally debate me. Anyway, if this is the first
time you're seeing me, my name is Z and please remember to follow
me to
>> Did she say we have to debate again? >> yourself
in my comment section because you're too scared to debate, just
formally debate me. Anyway, if this is the first time you've
seen me, my name is Z, and please remember to follow me to America.
Z Coquillette Sancheeze is the Jay Leno of political influencers
because she had a has a weird head and nobody likes her.
>> God. I want to make I want to make a joke about when
Jay Leno showed up with like the the Chud Logic look, okay, with
all the bandages and the bruises, but it's probably a little
too far. Okay.
All right.
All right, I think that's it for Z versus Taylor on Twitter.
Again, going back to my tweet, this guy says there's revenue
gains and losses.
I assume this is, and I don't know for sure, we could we could
look it up.
So, like, you look at their their incomes, they've got a thing
for revenues here. Yeah. So, revenues and support without donor
restrictions.
Where Wait, then there should be Is there revenue and support
with donor restrictions, or is there just not for I think that's
normally a section, but I don't know if it's here.
50 million and then 54 million in investment return net.
So, like, this is just their investment return, right? That's
like their income. I don't see where other incomes are coming
from.
And even if they were, this is for the 501c3, so they would just
be disclosed, right? Best Destiny stream in a while, and now
all the roaches are chasing the high. Dude,
it's just funny.
I ended up arguing with some people in the Lonerbox Discord.
I saw a message in the Lonerbox Discord that was like, "Uh this
reminds me of like my abusive ex who used to like gaslight me
and be passive-aggressive." And I'm like, "Dude, you've had that
idea entirely psyop'd into your head." Like, she is passive-aggressive,
but there's no gaslighting going on, right? Like, I just see
total cattle posting,
and it throws me through a loop. I like actually become enraged
looking at it.
Like, you have no internal monologue, you are not a human being
that exists, you are just total cattle. You are
You You have There's nothing You are insubstantial as a human
being.
You're You're actually insubstantial as a human being. It's crazy.
It's It's It's crazy. It's not that deep. No, it is that deep.
It is Missy, it is these people just like load up something and
they have no opinion of their own. Like they would be better
off doing literally anything else with their
But they have no opinions of their own. They have nothing going
on. It's It's
It's just like all a feedback loop for
And listen, it's not that deep. If they got out of it, they'd
be fine. But I'm just saying, within this system, they are total
cattle. It's very depressing to look at. Very depressing to look
upon. Apparently, Hasan pulled another Substance tweet today.
Hasan the Huns says it's unwise for Adam to be associated with
the America tour. Ooh. I think this is a mistake actually from
Hasan. I think it's a mistake. I think Hasan doesn't understand
that Adam Mockler's like DGG for life. I don't think I don't
think Adam Mockler's going to step off of this one.
I think that's his like true
truly like Yeah, just truly held belief, okay?
I I don't think so, but we'll see. Why would Gavin collab with
these sickos? Um he probably doesn't know.
Sicko week dems who think taking the high road means letting
the other side walk over as he probably just signed a hat or
held up a hat, you know what I mean? Why wasn't I mean, the real
question would just be why wasn't Destiny at an America event
with Gavin
Destiny's been carrying America.
Why would Destiny not be at the America event where Soy Pill
and Erodike got to meet Gavin Newsom and Gavin Newsom's holding
an America hat?
Why wouldn't Destiny be there? Wouldn't that be the real Why
What? >> I don't I don't know why Adam Mockler associates
with these freaks though. I'll be honest. Probably not good for
his brand.
>> Bro, Taylor Lorenz is still pumping out tweets tonight,
I think. Taylor Lorenz is a Twitter power user. Let's check this
out real quick. Uh Hutch is correct here. Pierre Omidyar's Don
Party's Investigative Journalism Fellowship is not dark money.
One, it's not political in nature, which it must be to be a dark
money program. And two, the funder is disclosed, Pierre Omidyar.
There are no outside funding sources. He funds it. So,
I think this is Think he was joking? Maybe he was joking. I think
this is just kind of like unquestionable.
Like, is it technically possible somebody else could fund it?
Yeah, technically it's possible,
but it makes no sense given the structure. And if they were interested
in doing that, there are ways they could structure it to make
it so they would get way more bang for their
Probably do a little hyperbole. Okay, based. What did Hutch say
here? >> Or probably that would be dark money. >> I
think I remember watching this Hutch clip and I was like, oh,
I think Hutch might have gotten this totally wrong. I think Hutch
is trying to remain consistent with some of his positions.
I don't I I think when I watched this on my phone, I don't think
I liked Hutch's take on it. >> thing that you're referring
to, that would be dark money. >> No, it's not dark money.
I know exactly who funded it. >> Destiny's getting confused
or maybe maybe I'm wrong, but the guy Omidyar, the guy with the
last name Omidyar, he has donated like $40 million to the What
is it called? The 1630 Fund? But I don't think that the group
that she is a part of, like this incubator program for journalists,
it's like a journalist cohort. I think that is directly funded
by that Omidyar guy, but it's not technically
dark money. But at that point, it's like, you know, she's taking
money from a guy who also gave $40 million to a dark money fund.
So, you know, I don't know. Yeah.
>> Yeah, Hutch is just kind of lost in every possible dimension
on this one. Not shocking. Not shocking. It's about par for the
course for what we expect from Hutch. Okay. This is I did Well,
she's taking money from somebody who does donate to dark money
funds. Isn't that bad? I don't think so. And does anybody realize
that every argument they're trying to apply to Taylor Lorenz,
if you sincerely believe it in any way, it means like Corus and
Progressive Victory would have been significantly
We understand that, right? That if you're like trying to apply
these arguments, that's why it's all internal critique of Lorenz.
That's why there's no actual critique of her whatsoever. It's
all just internal critiques.
Cuz for the people who actually critique in some way, all of
those critiques apply like triple back to you and people you
respect and like.
But Hutch just went with an actual critique, which reflects back
on him like worse or reflects back on the people around him worse.
So, I don't I don't know why he did that. It's very interesting.
Yeah,
Anyway. Anyway.
Yeah, so Taylor quote tweeting substance, you love to see it.
Love to see it. I think she had she had some other tweets here.
Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Oh, she tweeted with this guy as well. It's
very funny that even my most dedicated haters like Benjamin here
can admit that I don't take dark money, but Destiny, a Twitch
streamer doing IDF trips, can't seem to comprehend a journalist
not accepting dark money political payments.
I don't even know maybe this guy is a Taylor Lorenz hater. And
that would actually make sense if he was just based on, you know,
the fact that he's writing for the free press. Would make sense
if he's a Lorenz hater.
I It's is is such a stupid critique that so many people bought
into. It's like a completely critique. And I I hate to say I
think it's basically they were like, "Oh, Lunar Box looked into
it." And Lunar Box said this. We're just going to copy Lunar
Box cuz he looks into things and he knows.
And it's like, well, I think I think this one doesn't make any
sense, man. I think it just doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
It really doesn't.
She's in the trenches finding all the haters to reply to.
Wow. Oh, let's see here.
Confronting questions Taylor Lorenz on whether she she's funded
by dark money.
Reminder, Taylor Lorenz in an interview stated that you shouldn't
report on the facts, you should just reaffirm people and how
they feel if you're if you're reporting on a subject.
That sounds like that would not be good.
That sounds like that would not be a good way to be a journalist.
That sounds like you would have that clip and post it under all
of her stuff and she would be totally discredited as a journalist
if that clip existed.
Okay, let's see what Taylor said. Clip. Oh, Dickers is asking
for a clip. Very
I did not say that. Yeah, it seems like it'd be really unreasonable
for her to have said that. Feels like there's no way she would
have said that. Like at all. I don't know why people Why are
people dying on the dumbest hills for the chorus stuff? Stop
dying on the dumbest hills.
There are legitimate
critiques of her article, of her conduct. There are legitimate
critiques.
And nobody wants to make them. They're just making up total to
criticize her. I don't I don't get it. I don't
Was that just the only one? Credible. Okay, this is legit funny.
This definitely looks like nothing nothing nothing.
God. Uh what is the that dark money? Journalism fellowships are
common and Amediar's philanthropy is known. It's not. But just
uh but try explaining this to a Twitch streamer who doesn't understand
basic journalistic concepts or ethics and goes on spawn con trips
with the IDF. I don't think that's necessarily true. I think
he entertained the concept.
I don't know if he sponsored was sponsored to go on the previous
Israel trip. I sort of doubt it. Sort of doubt it. Put me aside.
You think oh, this is hold on. This is her like broader thread.
Put aside Put me aside. You think Julia Black and Carolyn Haskins
are taking political dark money? You're insane. The 1630 Fund
a well-known dark money org. A non-partisan investigative journalism
fellowship funded publicly by a billionaire is not a dark money
organization. If for no other reason than it's not a political
entity, and the funder is public.
But you don't know. You don't know. It's It's paid for by an
LLC ostensibly, although I don't know if that's even true. I
can't find out where it's paid how it's paid for, okay? I do
believe it's not a part of some grant from the 501c3, which leads
me to believe that it's a part of the LLC, okay? But that to
me doesn't necessarily mean that it's
a conflict of interest at all.
And if it were a conflict of interest, the other thing that needs
to be reinforced here, too, on the Taylor Lorenz front, is Pierre
Omidyar is a major donor to the 1630 fund, who is the donor to
Chorus. Where is the conflict of interest that's causing non-objectivity
on her part when she is actually reporting on on a thing? She
is acting as a way in a way as a reporter by reporting on this
that undermines Pierre Omidyar's political spending.
So what is What is the quid pro quo? What is the conflict of
interest that could possibly be happening when she accepts that
fellowship that's like affecting her objectivity? What What's
going on here? I I want any argument, any literally any argument.
Can somebody construct any argument? Anything. Any Anything.
Can we Anybody I'll talk to anybody.
But I ask like legitimate questions, and people just scatter
into the wind. Or they say things that are illiterate.
I have I have two kinds of people who will reply to me. They'll
go, "Oh, yeah, I think this is totally correct." And then another
kind of people who are totally illiterate.
And like basically they're like, "Well, actually when you look
at the financial disclosure, um well, actually when you look
at the financial disclosure over here, it says um it says things
about donor The word donor is there. And so, I think they take
donations from people through the LLC.
And it said donor. It's like, okay. Well, you know, I I mean,
technically, if a literacy is is, you know, just being able to
read the words, they can read the symbols and sound of the words,
but it doesn't connect to any deeper thought process,
It It connects to no deeper thought processes at all. And I'm
totally fine being wrong on this. I just want anybody to show
me where
where like you have any evidence Omidyar is taking any money
through his LLC, which would be totally moronic to do,
that's not from him. That's not just his funding for the LLC.
I literally don't get it. Wasn't Z accused of this? Z does run
Uh what is he Does he run a 501c3?
Hold on. What is America?
Hold on. What is Soul Strategies and and then America? America.
Is that Is that National Ground Game? National Ground Game is
Is that a project of National Ground Game? National Ground Game
is is a 501c4?
Where's Kilo? Is Is Nick Pack a 501c4?
Is that true? What is What is NGG? What is National Ground Game?
Yeah, but what is the What is the financial structure, the corporate
structure? Just waiting for a Kilo to answer me here in chat.
NGG, we're talking about National Ground Game Political Action
Committee, okay? NGG PAC.
Mmm G PAC. Mmm G PAC. Mmm G PAC, okay? I'll say it that way.
So I don't offend people. It's an LLC. Oh. Wait, then is she
not How is she raising money? Where are they Where are they raising
money from? Like, where do they take donations into? And is there
a way to run an LLC? This is what I'm asking. I'm literally just
asking for the information openly. Is there a way to run an LLC
such that you take like non-taxable
donations in? I would have thought you'd need a 501c3 or 501c4,
a nonprofit, to take those donations and not have them be taxed,
right? And so I would think National Ground Game would be something
that bills to whatever finance whatever donation raising like
entity she has.
Or is that incorrect? Cuz if that's incorrect, I'm fine with
that, but I'm just trying to figure it out. Yeah, well, Evil
Johnny Bravo, I think this is the way LLCs work. Technically,
you could have other owners there. It's just like what is the
likelihood that Pierre Omidyar for The Omidyar Network has other
owners? And then even if that's the case, it's like all under
his reputation with his direct backing and like his direct like
um
Like do we think Pierre Omidyar, a billionaire, is letting somebody
else use his name for their ends?
Right? Like like what is the what is the hypothesis for how somebody
else is putting money into Pierre Omidyar's Omidyar Network?
What is the what is the underlying hypothesis there? Because
I think people are like, "Well, it's technically possible." I
don't care if it's technically possible. Tell me what you think
is actually happening. Tell me what you think the odds are that
that is happening at all, that anybody else would put money in
here. Why does that make sense? Why is the thing you're saying
not categorically And I don't believe anybody will have a legitimate
answer for that. It will just be, "Well, shouldn't Taylor be
looking into this? Shouldn't Taylor be like paying attention
to this? Shouldn't Taylor be like like really concerned about
that?" No, why would she be? Why would anybody be? The the thing
you're proposing makes no sense. Like there are ways to hide
contributions and give money to people. There are ways to hide
your presence. Why would Pierre Omidyar let people like undermine
his goals and undermine his reputation by giving money on his
behalf? It's like technically you could spontaneously combust.
Shouldn't you have thought about that? Shouldn't you have thought
about the fact that you could spontaneously combust at any moment?
Are you really Are you really criticizing other people starting
forest fires when you could spontaneously combust at any moment?
Smokey the Bear? Hey, Smokey the Bear, can you really talk about
other people starting forest fires when you could spontaneously
combust at any moment? Go to the 60. I realize Oh, you're talking
about the Omidyar Network Services, right? I mean Omidyar Network
Services LLC Allied Cat Tails. I'm aware of 1630 giving $40,000
to
uh the Omidyar Network Services thing. I assume that is for services
rendered, right? It's the same argument I made for Z, which is
if you're just paying an LLC for services rendered, I don't think
that's inherently dark in any way.
Right? You're getting services back. You are getting things set
up. You're getting events set up. You're getting legal funding
or so you're getting legal
That's what that Omidyar Network Services LLC is. It's administrative
and legal representation.
Or administrative services, operational services, and legal representation.
They're just running their HR etc. Yeah, yeah. But like the um
Like I know that the 1630 Fund technically gave $40,000 of like
some contribution, but it's like such a it's such a tiny amount
of money that it's it's almost certainly just for some sort of
service. They probably had some corresponding like they probably
had some collaborative event going on and they just build out
to that company cuz that company was helping.
Or I guess I don't know what the strict If you're a 501c4 like
the 1630 Fund, when you pay a vendor, is that is that a grant?
I actually don't know. There might be some different financial
designation. It's how they get around setting up their own 501c,
but No, no, no, no, no. Omidyar Network has their own 501c. Omidyar
Network has a
The Omidyar Network is a 501c3
slash Chorus?
Oh, Chorus. Okay.
Sure, sure, sure. I don't know with Chorus how they're taking
that. It's like a program of the 1630 Fund, the Chorus incubator
thing. Sure. So, the funding Lorenz gets is the same as America.
No, it's not the same as on America either.
We're deep in the rabbit hole, I see here. Well, I I just want
to know cuz like I'm asking questions about people are are proposing
something that's like insane and they look totally ridiculous.
And then those same people would accuse me or people around me
of being totally biased on the subject. And I'm like, I'm just
asking legitimate questions that I think if you were acting in
good faith, you would give me the answers to.
Or you would have an answer to.
But I don't think anybody here is acting in good faith whatsoever.
Yeah, I don't know how America works to be honest. I know how
the 1630 fund works. I know how
I know how um Progressive Victory worked. It It's But I I think
I'm like correct in the things I'm asking and and looking into.
I can't get anyone to answer.
I Why won't you answer? Z Z Coen Sanchez, I want to have a conversation
with you. Z Coen Sanchez, you want to touch the tail of Lorenz?
Come talk to
Come talk to me. I'm literally asking for help. Z Z Coen Sanchez,
if you can hear me, I need your help, okay?
Can you hear me, Z? Z Z Coen Sanchez, can you hear me? He's scared
to do it. It's not even a debate. It's literally like I'm going
to be like, "So, I don't understand why you would set things
up this way."
Like the best what they're describing is like how is like these
billionaires there there there needs to be like a billionaire
who somehow is leverage over or somebody you know, who wants
to
somehow infiltrate Democratic operations through Pierre Omidyar
that has more influence and wealth than Pierre Omidyar who is
somehow using his name and his
to make political contributions that would undermine in some
way Democrats.
Cuz that's the concern when you don't know who the identity of
the funder is is that they're looking to undermine you in some
way. Or they're looking to like basically have some quid pro
quo. Well, we can't find a quid pro quo with regards to Pierre
Omidyar or any conflict there. Like Taylor is reporting on stuff
that negatively affects him and his investments, okay? And then
the other thing would be, well, they're trying to undermine things
by funding Taylor. It's like, okay, well, you could make that
argument, but then there apparently is somebody who is other
other than Pierre Omidyar, because you're arguing it's not transparent,
who's a part of his LLC, who's a part of the, you know, ownership
structure of his LLC, and has been putting their own resources
into this and is donating to Taylor Lorenz Taylor Lorenz under
Pierre Omidyar's name, but is undermining that
And it's like, well, do we think that's possible? Do we think
that's a thing that could happen? And they'll they'll always
just go, well, shouldn't Taylor know that?
No. You're You're actually asking for a level of scrutiny that
is insane, that is totally right. It's It's completely It's unthinkably
unfathomably stupid. You're You're describing a situation that
couldn't happen.
That's why That's why she's saying, no, it's not dark money,
because she's going you're You're describing something so stupid
that it is self-defeating. You're describing something so inherently
moronic that there is no response other than, well, this wouldn't
happen. Like, contrive the scenario where this happens. That's
the other tweet I did. I'm just like, dude, could somebody tell
me what would happen here? Could anybody tell me?
Like, what what is the scenario where this is a possibility,
right?
So, is there some reason I'm missing that a billionaire or group
of billionaires would use an LLC to obfuscate donations in a
non-tax exempt way when 501c4s exist? The entire idea that the
Omidyar LLC is being used to hide contributions of some kind
seems completely asinine. I That's the question for people. Why
would you take political contributions through an LLC
when that is the entire reason political nonprofits exist? So,
they're not So, it's not tax like taxable revenues you're collecting,
right? But So, to call it dark money, this is what you have to
This is the question you have to
You cannot call it dark money without answering this question
because you're implying that something untoward could be happening
there where it obviously wouldn't be happening. So, the responses
are, can you explain your complete ideological political ideological
change of the last 18 months? Outside of my view of Israel, very
little has changed with my worldview. Uh yes, they talk about
donors. Oh, they they oh the look they they donor. It said the
word donor here. Uh well, we know where this money come from
cuz it's from a media network doing services and then we know
this one is just investment return. Why talk about donors?
>> It said the word donor there. Okay. I
Okay, we're continuing.
The point is anyone can fund it.
But why would they fund it? Why would this suspicion happen?
Anyone could do anything. You could literally
The possibility,
mere possibility
that something could happen doesn't mean we should consider that
possibility
seriously. Okay? Well, I just Sorry, I'm literally I'm laughing
cuz I'm just like bro, I wish somebody
I'm asking the question that needs to be asked. I'm saying it
in a way that like I've looked into this a minimal amount.
Right? I'm getting into this a minimal a minimal amount and asking
real questions, but nobody wants to answer the questions.
And then the other two responses are The point is that dark money
as Taylor defines it is very stupid and not what she's not that
she's doing anything
It's not stupid.
It's literally a thing that people talk about. It's literally
the description of money that comes in via the Citizens United
ruling. Like the whole oh, you could get undisclosed you could
get massive amounts of money from undisclosed donors. This is
talking about a real problem and by the way, 1630 and Corus are
engaging in the thing that is a part of the real problem that
people talk about.
Taylor is not.
You're playing semantic games trying to get away from the actual
criticism here, and it's dog [__] You guys are the
people who aren't supposed to do this. You're the people who
are supposed to call it out. But instead I have to listen to
both Destiny and Lunar Box be this exact person that they claim
not to be, and it's very frustrating. Not on the Destiny front,
that guy has no principles. On the Lunar Box front, okay? Cuz
I sat here, and in every group chat, in every group chat, on
every stream, every time somebody came to me and said, "Lunar
Box is a piece of [__] Lunar Box is like a Zionist
piece of shit." I'm like, "Nope. Principled guy. Principled intelligent
guy. I like Lunar Box." Every single time. So all I'm all I'm
all I want is for maybe
Stop Just please engage with like some of the stuff I'm
And don't make me look like a stupid
Possibly. That's all I'm asking. That's all I'm asking, man.
[clears throat] I By the way,
I've not spent a lot of time looking into this. I could be totally
wrong. I could be totally wrong.
Right? But
I just want somebody to engage with it.
Just explain to me why I'm wrong. Yes, you you could do this
Ghost Cheese, but the reason they obfuscated this through the
Tenet LLC, right? The way they they did this with Tenet or the
way they would do it there is because it would be illegal to
do what they're doing. But it's not illegal to do this, and Sam
Omidyar or sorry, Pierre Omidyar has this tied directly to his
name. So why There's there's something going on where you're
you're describing something untoward. You're describing something
is happening incorrectly with with um the Omidyar Network LLC,
right? That he's getting money from a different national interest.
That something like this is happening. And it's like, "Well,
okay. One, he doesn't need money from a different national or
yeah, national interest. He's literally got all of the money
to run this fellowship himself.
The idea that the LLC is obfuscating funds in some way is just
silly. And that's not what political dark money is, right? That's
not That's not hiding the the names behind it. What Corus did
wasn't illegal, was it? No, it's not illegal. Nobody's alleging
what Corus is doing is illegal.
Nobody's alleging this.
But creators are required to disclose who they're being sponsored
by. No, they're actually not required to disclose this in this
case, Sophia.
Because they're not being They're not being paid to give opinions
on something. If you're sponsored to to run an ad for a product,
to shill something, you do need to disclose that. But the idea
here is that they're just being sponsored generally to do the
same thing they were already doing.
And so there is no required disclosure requirement. They should
be, yes, you should get changes to this. You shouldn't allow
somebody to take money from some huge
So from some huge, you know, dark money fund, and then they don't
have to disclose it. Absolutely.
That's the requirement. It doesn't require disclosure, Sophia.
Cuz tons of people aren't disclosing.
Tons of people have not disclosed that they're a part of There's
still a whole bunch of creators who are part of this the the
Corus Media Group's incubator program, who have never disclosed
that they're a part of that program. There is no legal requirement
for them to disclose, which is a part of the criticism, by the
way. Because in their contracts, it actually says, "Do not disclose.
You cannot disclose this. You cannot disclose this relationship
without talking to us first." And nobody's disputed that the
Corus contract said that. That sounds sus Yes, I know.
But apparently, the You want to talk about gaslighting? When
you say that's Oh, why are you working against Democrats? Why
are you working against Democrats right now? Why are you saying
this seems suspicious?
Why are you working against Democrats? Oh, you're just like a
Hasan fan who wants to kill Democrats, I guess.
Uh no.
Just asking reasonable questions over here. I thought we were
all against the Citizens United thing. Wasn't that like a thing
bunch of lefties decided a long time ago?
And by the way, if you're not against it, if you're like, "Oh
well, you know, it's an arms race. We need the money." Just make
that argument.
Just make that argument, man. Just make that argument. Uh okay.
Okay. Okay.
Well, we did the Candace thing. We did the We've farmed this
as much as I think I can. I If people want to keep linking tweets,
I'm down to keep covering this stuff, but I probably can't just
keep looking at all of myself.
Like on Twitter. Like I'm basically just like going back and
forth from to my Twitter feed.